este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a sur
shark vpn luego os doy más detalles pero
antes vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hoy voy a hacer una pregunta porque
rusia es tan grande vale ya lo sé
seguramente nunca os lo habías
preguntado pero pensando bien hablamos
del país más grande del mundo con nada
menos que nueve husos horarios distintos
hablamos además de un país donde
conviven decenas de culturas totalmente
diferentes por ejemplo todos sabéis que
la religión mayoritaria en rusia es el
cristianismo ortodoxo sin embargo rusia
tiene regiones enteras de mayoría
budista o incluso musulmana y la
pregunta es cómo han llegado hasta aquí
fue rusia siempre tan grande como os
podéis imaginar la historia de este país
está llena de grandes conquistas y si de
colonialismo
[Música]
podríamos decir que rusia ha sido un
gran imperio colonial aunque la pregunta
que nos hacemos en el vídeo de hoy es y
si rusia seguirá siendo un imperio
colonial incluso hoy en día dicho de
otra forma hasta qué punto la invasión
de vladimir putin en ucrania no es más
que un intento de evitar que ucrania se
independice de una vez por todas
tranquilos sé que muchos estaréis
removiéndose en la silla y os aviso que
el vídeo de hoy va a ser especialmente
polémico muy polémico y diréis pero por
qué pues porque fue precisamente la
unión soviética- quien más criticó los
imperios coloniales europeos fue de
hecho la unión soviética quien creó el
comité de descolonización en la onu y es
la rusia actual quien protesta cada vez
que eeuu abre una base militar en otro
país sin embargo la historia de rusia
tiene demasiadas cosas en común con las
de cualquier otro imperio colonial de
hecho el ex presidente checo vaclav
hável llegó a resumir la historia de
rusia con estas palabras atentos
el problema de rusia es que no sabe
dónde empieza y dónde termina vaclav
hável ex presidente checo así que la
pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es hasta
qué punto la unión soviética fue un
imperio colonial como lo pudo ser el
imperio español el británico o el
francés siguen existiendo colonias rusas
podríamos decir que ucrania es una
colonia rusa que quiere independizarse
porque hoy vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos a
ver cómo evitar que colonicen tu móvil o
tu ordenador si amigos de visual
política este es el momento en el que os
vamos a contar cómo navegar por internet
de forma segura y como podéis ver
páginas de cualquier parte del mundo sin
restricciones muchas ya sabéis la
respuesta es sur shark vpn y creedme el
tema de la ciberseguridad se lo toma muy
pero que muy en serio por ejemplo sur
shark tiene una herramienta que se llama
clean web que bloquea todos esos pop-up
es de propaganda por donde se cuelan un
montón de bots y cookies que francamente
no queremos tener por si todo esto fuera
poco con una única cuenta de surf shark
vpn podrás registrar todos los
dispositivos que quieras quieres navegar
con seguridad desde tu smartphone y
desde un teléfono móvil o desde tu
ordenador pues todo eso lo puedes hacer
con una única cuenta de surf
y por supuesto tenemos una oferta muy
especial para todos vosotros que seguís
visual polític básicamente si utilizáis
el código político terminado en acá
podréis disfrutar de un 83% de descuento
más tres meses extra totalmente
gratuitos tenéis todos los enlaces en la
descripción no esperéis más y
descargaros ya la aplicación y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la era de la descolonización
voy a hacer o es una pregunta son las
islas canarias una colonia española ya
lo sé ya lo sé y muchos de los españoles
que veis este vídeo os estaréis
sintiendo súper ofendidos pero creedme
fuera de españa- no creáis que todo el
mundo lo tiene tan claro atentos 17 de
junio de 2009 canarios y baleares
colonia según newsweek y miréis entonces
tanto las islas canarias como las islas
baleares están consideradas como
colonias en españa' de verdad tranquilos
ahora lo vamos a explicar pero antes
tenemos que entender que es la
descolonización para que os hagáis una
idea en el año 1945 más de un tercio de
la población mundial vivía en
territorios colonizados por una
metrópoli habéis oído bien pensad que
por aquella época prácticamente toda
áfrica pertenecía al imperio francés o
el británico india pakistán y bangladesh
eran colonias británicas y casi toda
indonesia pertenecía a países bajos y la
lista continúa es decir eran territorios
gobernados por una metrópoli los
ciudadanos de estos lugares no tenían
nada que decir sobre cómo se gobernaban
podríamos decir que vivían a efectos
prácticos en una dictadura y normalmente
vivían mal
[Música]
como ya os podéis imaginar la mayoría de
las élites políticas económicas en un
país como argelia por poner un ejemplo
eran franceses los argentinos nativos
poco disfrutaban de las ventajas
supuestas de pertenecer el imperio
francés así que en el año 1960 la unión
soviética llegó a la onu y dijo esto se
tiene que terminar los imperios
coloniales son cosas del pasado y así es
como se creó el consejo para la
descolonización de la onu y ya sólo que
pensar en algún consejo de la onu esto
suena a muchas declaraciones muchos
funcionarios diciendo que estan deeply
concern y poco más verdad pues nada de
eso los años 60 son precisamente los
años de la descolonización en muy poco
tiempo casi todas las antiguas colonias
en áfrica y en asia se independizaron de
sus metrópolis y es más según la propia
onu hoy en día sólo quedan 8 territorios
en el mundo sin autogobierno pero
tranquilos porque en esta lista
encontramos lugares como gibraltar en
fin creo que muchos de vosotros
estaríais encantados de vivir en
gibraltar sobre todo después de haber
visto todos los vídeos que hemos hecho
aquí en visual político sobre este lugar
y por si algunos lo estaba pensando no
ni las islas canarias ni las islas
baleares están en la lista de
territorios colonizados y diréis por qué
pues porque los ciudadanos de canarias o
los de baleares son tan españoles como
cualquier otro votan en las elecciones
igual que alguien de madrid o de sevilla
y tienen los mismos derechos y
obligaciones ahora bien de verdad
podemos decir que esta lista está
completa pensadlo bien fue la unión
soviética quien propuso crear un comité
de descolonización en los años 60 pero y
si los soviéticos fueran también un
imperio colonial atentos porque ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
porque rusia es tan grande
voy a volver a la pregunta del principio
porque rusia es tan grande ya os digo
que en el siglo 16 rusia era mucho más
pequeña atentos a este mapa
[Música]
sin embargo por estas fechas es con dhul
zar iván el terrible inició su expansión
hacia el este como os podéis imaginar
hablamos de zonas prácticamente
inhabitadas más que nada porque nadie
podía vivir ahí por ejemplo en esta
época es cuando se empieza a colonizar
siberia que en fin creo que estaremos
todos de acuerdo en que no es
precisamente el paraíso ahora bien por
estas tierras había tribus y pueblos
nómadas y como os podéis imaginar a iván
el terrible le llamaban iván el terrible
por algo sin embargo el gran colonizador
de nuestra historia fue nada menos que
pedro el grande llamado así porque fue
el que agrandó el imperio ruso hasta
prácticamente lo que conocemos hoy en
día por cierto que a mí siempre me ha
parecido fascinante que en aquella época
sin tecnología ni nada parecido pudieran
colonizar algo tan grande y tan
inhóspito como siberia
pero no sólo hablamos de siberia el
imperio ruso se extendía a muchas zonas
que sí estaban habitadas desde el
cáucaso hasta parte de polonia o incluso
lo que hoy en día es ucrania y así es
como llegamos al año 1917 y que pasen
este año seguramente esta parte de la
historia rusa la conozcáis todos exacto
es el año de la revolución bolchevique
[Música]
como ya sabrá alguno por aquí el
marxismo clásico dice que las naciones
no son importantes que el sentimiento
nacional es un invento porque es verdad
es del famoso proletarios del mundo
uníos fuera fronteras todos somos
iguales ante el paraguas de la clase
obrera sin embargo que creéis que se
encontraron los comunistas rusos nada
más llegaron al poder pues se dieron
cuenta de que rusia era mucha rusia
vamos que era un país muy grande por
ejemplo en la zona de kalmukia buriatia
tenían a tribus chamánicas y budistas en
georgia por ejemplo hablaban un idioma
rarísimo que tenía hasta su propia
grafía ponte tú a extender la dictadura
del proletariado en semejantes indios en
semejante torre de babel
[Música]
sin embargo no os preocupéis porque los
bolcheviques habían hecho sus deberes
para que el entonces el señor joseph
stalin había escrito ya un libro muy
interesante titulado marxismo y cuestión
nacional pensando bien stalin había
nacido en georgia es decir que venía de
una de estas zonas que había sido
colonizada por rusia como diríamos hoy
en día stalin tenía una enorme
sensibilidad por las minorías étnicas
ellas es lo que estaréis pensando stalin
de verdad estamos hablando del mismo
stalin de las purgas el hiper
centralismo y los gulags pues si el
mismo la vida da muchas vueltas pero de
eso vamos a hablar más tarde lo cierto
es que en 1917 stalin defendía la
autonomía regional es decir que cada
pueblo dentro de rusia pudiera hablar su
idioma y tener hasta sus propios
gobiernos por supuesto todos ellos
debían formar parte del mismo partido
comunista es decir en lo que a
relaciones de clase se refiere todos los
propietarios tenían que dejar sus
fronteras nacionales aparte pero fuera
del mundo del trabajo el propio stalin
reconocía el derecho a mantener la
cultura propio y así es como nació la
llamada
atentos que ahora viene una palabrota de
las buenas que oren y sat silla que era
una política para promover a la gente
local en puestos de administración
incluso llegarán a crear los llamados
atentos que ahora viene otra palabrota
aún peor nada soviet y que eran consejos
para representar a las minorías étnicas
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea el propio
stalin llegó a abrir escuelas donde se
enseñaba ucraniano esto puede parecer es
muy normal hoy en día pero era todo un
cambio de mentalidad en aquella época
para el ruso medio no era del todo fácil
asumir que el resto de etnias dentro de
la propia rusia tenían derecho a usar su
propia lengua y mantener su cultura
pensado además que durante siglos los
zares habían intentado imponer el ruso y
la religión ortodoxa con calzador en
todos los territorios en que estaban sin
embargo stalin tenía muy claro que no se
podía reconstruir un país sin dar poder
a las regiones incluso llegaron a sacar
políticas de discriminación positiva
para promover las lenguas locales por
encima del ruso en otras palabras que si
estarían podría mandar a disidentes al
gulag sin pestañear pero en lo que a
sensibilidad con otras naciones se
refiere parecía un hippie abraza a
árboles cual diríais que es el problema
con todo esto
pues que para mediados de los años 30 la
población rusa empezó a enfadarse en
muchos casos la discriminación positiva
dejaba los rusoparlantes en una
situación muy pero que muy mala o al
menos así lo sentían dentro del propio
partido comunista empezaron a existir
grandes debates y para 1938 a stalin no
le quede otro remedio que decretar el
ruso como idioma obligatoria en toda la
unión soviética durante las próximas
décadas toda esa sensibilidad con
distintas naciones que conforman el
crisol cultural socialista que era la
unión soviética desapareció de hecho
para el año 1980 prácticamente todas las
posiciones del politburó estaban
ocupadas por rusos sin embargo todo esto
es lo que ocurría dentro de la unión
soviética ahora vamos a ver lo que
ocurría fuera y creerme si esto no tiene
al menos tintes clarísimos de
colonialismo entonces yo soy santa claus
[Música]
pacto de varsovia
para la segunda guerra mundial eeuu
reino unido y francia se reparte en
europa junto con la unión soviética y
qué criterio usaron para repartirse a
europa pues en muchos casos
arbitrariedad pur y dura el más hay
muchos ejemplos donde los soviéticos se
quedaron con países enteros simplemente
porque llegaron unos días antes que los
británicos o los americanos y así es
como la unión soviética creó un área de
influencia que incluía países como
polonia la antigua checoslovaquia y
hungría de la noche a la mañana estos
países pasaron a tener sistemas
comunistas y diréis pero cómo funciona
esto es decir de repente de la noche a
la mañana en hungría decidieron votar al
partido comunista en masa pues lo cierto
es que no por ejemplo hungría celebró
elecciones en 1945 justo después de
haber sido liberados por los soviéticos
que mantenían su presencia militar en el
país en estas elecciones el partido
comunista saca un poco más del 17 por
ciento del voto pero los soldados
soviéticos se encargarán de intimidar a
los políticos de la oposición y poco a
poco los comunistas fueron haciéndose
con todo el poder diez años más tarde en
1956 se produce la revolución húngara es
decir que muchos húngaros anti
comunistas se levanta en armas contra el
gobierno comunista pero entonces desde
moscú se encargaron de sofocar la
revuelta y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando muchos era la guerra fría todos
cometieron excesos verdad pues si a la
vez no a estas alturas nadie puede negar
que eeuu también intervino en un montón
de países para evitar que se crearan
gobiernos comunistas pero como en todo
en esta vida hay grados
la guía ha movido hilos en todo el mundo
para evitar el auge del comunismo esto
es cierto pero también es cierto que en
plena guerra fría en los años 80 francia
llegó a tener incluso un gobierno de
coalición entre socialistas y comunistas
y nadie envió los tanques a parís para
evitarlo dicho de otra forma una todas
son movimientos en la sombra espionaje y
propaganda y otra muy distinta es una
invasión en toda regla y diréis pero de
verdad la unión soviética invadió algún
país pues sí y esto nos lleva a hablar
de la primavera de praga la historia de
como los comunistas llegaron al poder en
checoslovaquia daría en sí mismo para un
vídeo y ya os aviso que esta historia
incluiría asesinatos a políticos
tirándoles por la ventana o como dirían
los soviéticos
suicidios pero lo dicho esto es otra
historia para otro vídeo porque después
de 20 años de comunismo checoslovaquia
el gobierno de este país decidió dar un
pequeño cambio de rumbo hablamos del
llamado socialismo con rostro humano o
como lo llamó la prensa de entonces la
primavera de praga
el por entonces presidente checoslovaco
alexander dubcek quería reformar el
socialismo por ejemplo proponía
legalizar el multipartidismo o permitir
libertad de expresión al menos hasta
cierto punto es decir podríamos decir
que buscaba algo parecido a una
socialdemocracia y que creéis que
hicieron desde moscú pues el 20 de
agosto de 1968 la unión soviética mando
doscientas mil tropas y dos mil tanques
a praga en unos pocos días toda
checoslovaquia estaba bajo el control
absoluto soviético no sé si sois
conscientes de lo que hablamos pero
entre 1968 y 1989 todas checoslovaquia
es decir la actual chequia y eslovaquia
tenían cerradas las fronteras esto
significa que miles de familias quedaron
rotas para siempre y el gobierno del
país quedó completamente en manos de
moscú fin de cuentas cualquier ligero
desencuentro con el politburó
significaría una nueva invasión dicho de
otra forma que tanto ucrania como
checoslovaquia o incluso polonia
tuvieron gobiernos independientes
solamente en nombre no tenían libertad
ni para convocar elecciones ni tampoco
para poder sacar sus propias leyes como
quisieran y la pregunta es hasta qué
punto esto no se podrían considerar
colonias
[Música]
a la lista
pero ojo porque no solo hablamos de
europa los mismos ejemplos se pueden
encontrar en todos los países de asia
central desde kazajistán hasta mongolia
el caso de mongolia es especialmente
llamativo tradicionalmente los mongoles
han tenido más lazos con los chinos que
con los rusos sin embargo la influencia
soviética llegó hasta tal punto que los
mongoles tuvieron incluso que cambiar su
grafía por el cirílico y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando pero vale muy bien y
todo esto que tiene que ver con la rusia
actual todo el mundo sabe que la unión
soviética se desintegró en 1990 desde
entonces todos esos países que en su día
formaron parte de la unión soviética son
ahora naciones independientes la
pregunta es de verdad lo son dejando a
un lado el conflicto de ucrania tenemos
muchos más ejemplos desde la guerra de
georgia en 2008 hasta la intervención en
kazajistán este mismo año y aquí es
donde llega la gran pregunta que dejamos
en este vídeo hasta qué punto no
deberíamos entender a rusia como un gran
imperio colonial que se resiste a
desaparecer y si el conflicto de ucrania
fuera un episodio más de un imperio que
se resigna a disolverse qué impacto
puede tener todo esto a nivel
diplomático podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual y
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribirse a este canal y dadle
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]